c'est ce moment que vous attendez le
site uhry tu perds aujourd'hui ce qu'un
chauffeur l'a26 tu récupères le premier
duel oppose jean marie bigard à bouder
c'est très simple on va démarrer avec
jean-marie qui va prendre de l'eau dans
la bouche à montereau jean marie c'est
parti bach lauder va se dire une blague
attention tu la cabab toujours plus
cependant plus beaucoup de pros - keita
il m'a dit fais toi plaisir que le sait
qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de boire d'eau
jean-marie mais fait-on plaisir c'est un
pistolet il croise une mitraillette et
lydie dont pistonné diane et me traitent
tu paye toujours autant attention
jean marie bat vaste soit noyé selon son
mari s'est alors servi ni comment bouder
ça c'est la blague c'est ça des voitures
marié tu peux reprendre ici où tu sens
la lune tu peux y être là ne meurt
jamais une zee
[Applaudissements]
or des enveloppes de bouche banny tu
marques tu sais quelle différence il ya
entre une climatisation
il habite alors il n'y en a pas parce
que si tu la bouche trop fort ça fait
mal à la gorge
quel os [ __ ] oui la qualité
face à lui des villes est en train de
tout bien prochain c'est un mec 40 dans
un bar et qui dit salut c'est moi en
fait c'était pas lui fit à gagner si
désolée barcelone et rs sera l'hôte
atteinte à gagner est qualifié de
paisibles son camp ce lycée patu presque
est pas resté là on a trouvé sur quoi
elle va faire comme moi c'est bien sûr
ça elle va tous nous asperger sur abc
sûr je suis qu'on appelle t-on un cadeau
qui s'en va une surprise partie jouée
par cinq femmes fontaines
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais dire ça me sentais je ne boirai
pas de ton nom et c'est tout ludivine
s'arracher aux tensions
l animal peut lire l'avenir la boule de
cristal a passé la soirée
et va boire coup les verts condamnent tu
peux la faire pour qu'elles vont être
effectués vous crachez pour gagner à
vous ouais en fait c'est quand tu
craches alors que tu gagnes là vous êtes
qualifiés tous et tous cas on n'est qu'à
la fin je sais pas pourquoi vous êtes
qualité d'accord pas des bois a gagné
c'est bon c'est bon ça c'est mon ami tu
encore un peu de monsieur el tri shalom
a gagné une encyclopédie des meilleurs
emplacements de camping car on aimerait
noir c'est une jcct cette deuxième
question serait ce qu une gousse na et
jeté contre un mur et qui revient c'est
le retour du jedi
c'est dans ces villes fait cyril pour
toi
[Applaudissements]
pas drôle ludivine sorriaux et sa
pression du maître jean marie au fait
pourquoi napoléon n'a jamais acheté deux
maisons bateaux là parce qu'il avait
déjà un bonaparte ou non merci on va
gagner toutes les deux comme en ramasse
ton la papaye and on dit au coach comme
avec une fourche et où aller c'est sur
un mec 15,5 bits
[Rires]
j'aimerais un petit face à face jean
marie bigard oui mais très proche à 10
cm oui les gars face à francisco eric
boyer qui vous voulez choisir si je
regarde si on est bien proche mairie
c'est jean marie qui prend l'eau pour
l'instant c'est lui
walo walo d'abord jean brilleaud
approchant les chérir approchez vous
vendez raconte l'histoire où vous aimez
c'est l'histoire d'un papy qui tombe à
l'eau est écrite de suite au secours
j'ai papier à toi aussi tu peux course
et moi c'est moi c'est un nouveau verre
t'inquiète pas on a budget ou oui alors
à koné je reste que deux trous dans un
trou s'est tourné dans mon cul
on se voile s'était pas ludivine catteau
rabia quatre pôles bouder simon brière
écoute tu me feras paris je pense aux
assedic de fait le choix n'est pas dit
ces deux grands sables qui arrive sur la
plage y en a eu un petit chat c'est
blindé aujourd'hui tu connais toi toi tu
bois
c'était sûr qu'elle n'est pas potable
aux crêtes jc cent des trucs très fort
en haut c'est l'examen final dans un
hôpital psychiatrique examen final il
les emmène tous à la piscine mais la
piscine elle est vide alors tous les
fouilles sont dans la piscine est vive
la porte je vous donne à fond des plats
y en a mais à un mec il est debout comme
ça ils bougent pas un des fous qui bouge
pas donc les docteurs disent ben lui
c'est bon il est sauvé ils vont le voir
ni pourquoi tu suis pas avec les
hollandais moi je suis maître nageur n'a
pas craché à la gueule de bois le dit
voilà regarde bien dans les yeux bon moi
s'y côtoient cyril a besoin de toi ça va
gicler les tirs il passa par l'emploi
aussi beaucoup ça passe vite avant qui
te vendent des roses pris pour une
deuxième cycliste c'est un premier est
la voie la fois après quoi sert il
apporta à dire un speed dating en
tunisie
sérieusement approche la série voilà tu
cours tu as blacks on a droit de tous
prendre de l'eau et tous se mettent là
peut-être que franchement algérie tue
pas les y conçoit réalise et basile en
ville de huy génial ça apprenez tous de
l'eau les gars savent est une benne tout
ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
gelabale comment s'appelle regarde moi
bien au cou
comment s'appelle le cul de la
schtroumpfette
l'amour est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]